>>Female Presenter: So, today we're pleased
to welcome Jon Gertner, author of " The Idea
Factory: Bell Labs and the Great Age of American
Innovation."
In this book, Gertner unveils the unique magic
of Bell Labs through the eyes and actions
of its scientists.
Even more importantly, he reveals the forces
that set off such an explosion of creativity.
Jon has also been a contributing writer at
The New York Times Magazine, where he writes
about business, technology and society.
Please join me in welcoming Jon.
[ applause ]
>>Jon Gertner: Thanks.
Can everybody hear me OK?
Thank you for coming.
I really appreciate it.
One of the strange things about working on
a book for 5 years, which I'll put up there.
Oops, sorry.
There we go.
Is that you're on your own for a while.
You're really living this introverted existence.
Then, you are done with the book and everybody
expects you to be this wonderfully extroverted
person who can deliver dynamic speeches and
captivate audiences.
I think I can write better than I can speak,
but I will do my best.
Today, I am going to talk a little bit about
Bell Labs.
It's a huge, it was a huge endeavor.
It was a huge organization.
It lasted in its, I guess, in its real, pure
incarnation before the phone monopoly was
broken up from 1925 until 1984.
Early on, when I was working on the book,
I realized I could probably spend the rest
of my life writing a book about Bell Labs.
I mean, there was this sort of bottomless
amount of information.
And if you guys ever want to archive it that
would be great because it's all millions of
documents arranged pell-mell in the archives.
So, this was a classic endeavor, I think,
where there was too much information.
And some of the challenge was to sort through
and find a way to tell the story.
Does everybody--.
I don’t know if everyone knows what Bell
Labs was, but it was the R and D arm of AT
and T. AT and T was a different organization
back then.
It was the telephone monopoly in control of
between 80 and 90 percent of the telephone
service in the United States.
AT and T was vertically integrated.
It had Bell Labs as its R and D organization
on the bottom.
It controlled a manufacturing company called
Western Electric, too.
AT and T, itself, ran the long distance service.
And it owned either pieces or whole entire
parts of these local operating companies around
the country.
It was the biggest company in the world at
the time.
It employed the most people.
It was the most valuable.
It was a true colossus at the time.
The reason to, for me at least, to write about
Bell Labs was this, which is a, probably a
info-graphic you definitely cannot read from
there.
But a guy at the Times did this for me when
I wrote a story a couple weeks back about
why it matters.
But, all those little blurbs there are Bell
Labs innovations that as we move along the
time line, kind of coalesce into this wondrous
electronic world we have today.
And just on a quick short list, if I were
going to tick-off some of the big accomplishments
and innovations there, probably the things
got rolling in its golden age in 1947 with
the invention of the transistor.
Many iterations of the transistor followed.
Many process innovations for the transistor
followed as well.
The silicon solar cell came out of there.
Digital communications and information theory
came out of there.
Cellular telephone networking came out of
there.
UNIX, the C language, digital signal processing--
[clears throat] I'm sure Ileft out a few.
Communication satellites, wavelength multiplexing,
fiber optics themselves were not originated
there, but fiber optic systems did.
So, you can see that these were true platform
innovations on which the industries of today
were built.
And for me the question was how do I, why
did that happen?
Why was this one place so creative, so innovative
for so long?
One reason is it was connected to a monopoly
and it had this endless stream of money and
it could hire the best people.
Create the, any kind of equipment.
Nothing was too expensive.
It could think long term in a way that is
harder today I think.
It could do science experiments in a way that
is harder today, too, for corporations to
invest in things that are quite so risky.
Anyway, quickly I think today I will just
talk about two innovations in particular and
maybe give you a flavor for how innovation
happened there, which is definitely different
from today.
And also you can ask me questions after, but
also I think these examples work together
in a complimentary way.
And explain a little bit of how things began.
This is Murray Hill, which some of you may
have heard of or maybe not.
The original Bell Labs was actually here in
Manhattan on West Street, about 20 blocks,
25 blocks.
A few less actually.
About 10, 15 blocks south of here.
In the early 40s, they built this as a sort
of escape from the city.
They wanted to do their experiments away from
the dirt and the noise and the vibrations
of New York.
This was the first building.
Many more followed.
It became quite an enormous complex.
It still stands today.
It's actually the headquarters of Alcatel-Lucent
at the moment.
But in the time that this photo was taken,
which was I think about 1946 or 47, it was
just about entering its golden period.
And it was where a lot of the great researchers,
who later became famous, worked.
There a couple of other campuses in New Jersey
as well.
But this was in that era the primary one.
This guy on the left was Mervin Kelly.
And in someways he really forms the back bone
of my book.
He started at Western Electric in 1917.
And came over to Bell Labs in 1925.
The picture on the left is him in his early
career.
The one on the right is Kelly before he retired
in the late 50s.
Its also probably a good ad for why you shouldn’t
smoke cigarettes.
Kelly was a heavy smoker [chuckles] and it
aged him pretty seriously.
His first job at Bell Labs, or his first big
job, was to be in charge of vacuum tube development.
And vacuum tubes, as you may know, as one
of these great technologies that has entered
the dust bin of history.
Almost.
Unless you are a guitar player and you use
tube amps.
Or you're into high- powered radio transmission
and they still require some of that.
But at the time, the vacuum tube was really
the great invention of Kelly's time.
And what it did, as you may know, is it allowed
telephone calls to actually travel across
the country.
Telephone signals were not digital at the
time.
They were traveling by waves.
They are weak.
They attenuate.
The vacuum tubes, in fact-- this is the one
Kelly worked on for years and years called
the 101 D-- was also called the repeater tube.
And these tubes were spaced every 50 to 75
to 100 miles across the country at repeater
stations.
Phone calls that were going from New York,
for instance, to Menlo Park, would travel
through many of these repeater stations as
the signal would be amplified and sent on
farther along the line.
Kelly was really good at his job.
He ran the vacuum tube shop and it gave him
deep appreciation of an incremental innovation,
I guess you might say.
He worked on getting cost down and the life
of these things up.
I think he brought the hours they could run
from something like a thousand hours to 80
thousand hours, which was a phenomenal achievement.
And obviously, economics of that were tremendous
as well.
But he fundamentally had a problem with vacuum
tubes.
He probably knew as much or more about vacuum
tubes than anybody in the country.
He felt deeply that they were a flawed technology.
He would complain to his wife that they broke
all the time.
The other problems with vacuum tubes is they
were fairly large as you can see.
This one was just a little bit smaller than
an old style incandescent light bulb.
They used great amounts of power.
They gave off tremendous amounts of heat.
They had to warm up to function, so they couldn’t
function cold.
And it had bothered him.
He was always wondering if there was something
else that could replace them.
Kelly had a best friend at Bell Labs and his
name was Clinton Davisson.
He won the Nobel Prize in the late 1930s.
But before either one of these guys became
famous, they shared a laboratory in the teens
and 20s at Bell Labs.
They were kind of the original odd couple.
Kelly was robust.
He had extraordinary amounts of energy.
I wonder if he might have had A.D.D.
He was in those days before then he was always
on the move.
He was not somebody who would linger over
things too long.
Davisson was the opposite.
Kelly was a fairly good sized man.
Davisson was incredibly thin, phlegmatic,
slow moving.
I think Davisson weighed 110 pounds, sometimes.
He would often be sick.
He would go home and he would wear his stocking
cap and his little nightgown, and sit in his
study at home and write equations.
And Kelly would go visit him and see how he
was doing.
They shouldn’t have got along in theory,
but they did.
And Kelly actually was awed by Davisson.
In some ways, it speaks to why Kelly was so
good at what he did, and why Bell Labs became
what it became.
The thing about Davisson was that he couldn’t
help his colleagues with the actual engineering
of the projects they were working on.
But what he could do was he could answer questions
nobody else in the staff of Bell Labs could
do.
He would give them a deeper, more fundamental
understanding.
For instance, with vacuum tubes and what was
going on deep within the processes of these
tubes.
And what Kelly realized was yes, Davisson
could answer questions nobody else could.
But that by imparting a kind of fundamental
understanding of what was happening with these
electronic devices, staff under him at the
tube shop, for instance, could make improvements
that were not just twice as good or three
times as good, but orders of magnitude better.
It showed him that knowledge gives an unbelievable
power beyond just mere tinkering.
And in many ways, Davisson became the model
for those Bell Lab researchers.
In later years, not everybody was in research
at Bell Labs.
A lot of people were in development.
In fact, the majority were.
But those researchers who were pursuing pure
knowledge and could be tapped for that, Davisson
was Kelly's model.
So, it's one day in 1937 and Kelly's walking
down the hall and he is likely on his way
to visit Davisson because Davisson shares
an office with a guy right below him.
On that picture, Davisson is on the right
and Shockley-- William Shockley-- is right
below him.
Shockley had joined Bell Labs
in 1936.
Kelly had hired Shockley.
Shockley was brilliant.
He grew up in Palo Alto.
He went to graduate school at MIT.
And for whatever reason, that day Davisson
was likely not there and Kelly decides to
give Shockley a speech.
And Kelly tells him rather than talking about
vacuum tubes that day, he is complaining about
switches.
These relay switches that clicked on and off.
And they were the other essential part of
The Bell System.
They were electromagnetic.
They were slow in a manner of speaking because
they weren’t electronic.
They clicked and moved.
They broke fairly often.
They wore out.
They were a huge expense.
There were millions of them in the system.
And he told Shockley that day in 1937, and
it was something Shockley would remember for
the rest of his life: “If we could just
get these switches out of the system somehow,
if there was someway to replace them, it would
just be an enormous improvement for The Bell
System.”
There are then these two components-- the
amplifying tubes and the switches--both of
which are essential to making The Bell System
function, both of which are problematic.
And Shockley takes this to heart.
The war intervenes in 1941 and all of Bell
Lab starts working on war-related stuff.
[clears throat] And then right after the war,
Kelly creates what later became known as The
Solid State Team.
He got a group together at Bell Labs, put
Shockley in charge, and asked them to look
into the nature of semiconductors.
And semiconductors were relatively new, I
guess you could say, semi-understood material
at the time.
They had become very valuable in war-time
radar.
But Kelly and others at Bell Labs felt that
there was still a good deal amount to know
about them that they did not.
And the semiconductor group was interesting
for a couple of reasons.
It sounds a little bit obvious today, but
it was tremendously interdisciplinary, which
Kelly personally believed was necessary.
So, it wasn't just physicists working together.
And it wasn't just experimentalists and theorists.
There were chemists.
There were electrical engineers.
There were circuitry experts.
Everybody was pitching in with somewhat complimentary
talents.
Not everybody agreed.
There was a nice amount of creative tension
as well.
The second thing about the group that was
fairly interesting, is that in some ways,
Kelly's entire career had been built upon
his achievements with the vacuum tube.
And what he is doing in some ways is trying
to get away or get around that innovator's
dilemma.
He's essentially creating a team that, if
it succeeds, will make his entire previous
career at Bell Labs and all his fame really,
somewhat irrelevant.
From 1945 to 1947, the transistor group goes
to work.
They're not the transistor group.
Excuse me.
They're the semiconductor group.
And in fall of 1947, two guys working under
Shockley, John Bardeen and Walter Brattain
, come up with this,which is very ugly, but
quite miraculous.
Its about--.
If anybody's ever seen it, it's actually about
the size of the tip of my pinky.
So it's fairly small.
And that sheet of crystal underneath the arrow
head is germanium.
It's not silicon.
Its lightly doped germanium.
And on the side of that arrow head are gold
wires coming in there.
And on the day before Christmas Eve, Bardeen
and Brattain with Shockley there, too, demonstrated
to the Bell Labs executives.
And they amplified their voice somewhat like
18 times.
And they agreed that it was something tremendously
big.
So they found this thing, this punitive replacement
for the vacuum tube.
And it seemed that the world would change.
But it didn’t because what they discovered
pretty quickly was how hard these things were
to make.
In those early days, I would go through all
these stories and Bell Labs guys bringing
in military generals, or heads of corporations,
to see this wondrous new transistor.
But if it was a humid day the thing would
stop working.
If somebody slammed a door nearby it wouldn’t
work.
There were tremendous challenges in manufacturability.
Eventually, those were worked out.
And eventually, too, Shockley created the
idea for something called the junction transistor.
Still later there were other things like the
field effect transistor that came into play.
And one by one, these problems of manufacturing
were solved by Western Electric factories
with the help of the development team at Bell
Labs.
And by the early 1950s, these transistors
were just starting to make their way into
the electronics industry.
And then at about that same time, in actually
the same lab that the transistor was made,
these three guys were working on it.
It was 1954.
So, the development of the transistor was
continuing, but it was, again, starting to
infiltrate culture and business.
And the guy on the far left is Gerald Pearson,
who actually shared an office with Walter
Brattain, who was one of the inventors of
the transistor.
And Pierson, with the guy on the right, Cal
Fuller, were working on something called a
silicon solar rectifier.
I'm sorry, a silicon power rectifier.
Excuse me.
Pearson was an experimental physicist.
Fuller was a chemist.
And what Fuller would do is he would make
these pieces of silicon in his lab that were
diffused.
And he would put these light layers of slightly
impure, slightly doped we call it now.
They didn’t call it that at the time.
They called it N or P silicon.
On these silicon wafers and he would bring
it to Pearson.
And they would try and work out this device
they were making for the phone system.
What Pearson started to realize is that this
stuff that Fuller was making was incredibly
photosensitive, not just surprisingly slow,
but had a larger effect than anything Pearson
could find in the science literature, and
anything he had ever seen before.
And that struck him.
What also struck him was he knew a guy in
the middle from college named Daryl Chapin.
Now, all these guys actually worked in different
buildings.
And they just serendipitously almost found
each other.
What Pearson knew about Chapin was that Chapin
was actually looking for a way to solve a
problem that he was working on at Bell Labs
that had to do with those old repeater stations
I was talking about.
They were spaced again every 50 to 100 miles
around the country.
And they amplified phone calls.
In some rural areas, these repeater stations
didn't have a real reliable power source,
especially in the south.
They used dry cell batteries that would sometimes
stop working, or they used diesel generators.
And what Pearson realized, thinking he had
been having lunch with Chapin and knew what
he was trying to work on, was that this thing
that he and Fuller were also working on, too,
could possibly be used as a power source for
this problem.
So, the three men went to work on this.
And eventually, they came out with what was
called The Bell Solar Battery, or the silicon
solar cell.
And it was tried in 1955 at Americus, Georgia.
And it was very successful.
I'll talk about the economics of it in a second.
But in terms of its function, it worked very
well.
And in fact, it's interesting, too.
I live in New Jersey and these are going up
on every phone pole now, too.
Except they are a lot thinner and obviously
the efficiencies are much higher.
A couple things to just draw from these two
examples I think, or at least things I found
interesting as I was researching and thinking
hard about what it means.
I think, first, in these two cases it can
demonstrate that innovation is often a response
to needs and to problems, rather than that
classic lone inventor coming up with the idea.
That it's rarely an unprovoked idea.
That, at least for the transistor team, they
were looking into the deeper nature of their
materials.
And in the back of their mind they had, at
least Shockley very much had that idea, that
if they found something it could be quite
useful for the phone system.
It could get rid of those proliferating switches
and tubes.
The solar cell, for instance, was a very clear
response to a problem that Daryl Chapin had.
I think the second thing we learn is that
we're not very good at perceiving breakthroughs
sometimes when they happen.
The transistor ended up on page 46 of The
New York Times.
And it was actually not even at the top of
this trivial column.
It was located deep down at the bottom.
Saying all these Bell Labs guys might have
a replacement for the vacuum tube.
At Bell Labs, they thought it was quite a
big deal, but it was hard for the rest of
the country and in fact, the world, to perceive
its immediate import.
Or at least most people.
With The Bell Solar Battery, which is quite
interesting, is almost the exact opposite.
It was a miracle.
[chuckles]
It was a pivotal juncture of mankind.
It was on the front page of most newspapers
in the country.
We had harnessed the power of the sun.
And I'm a big solar power advocate, so I'm
not knocking it, but at the time it seemed
like things had changed dramatically.
That we had tapped now a cheap inexhaustible
source of power that would change our culture
and our society.
But to build on that too, I think there's
a third thing.
And that's that invention is fairly-- can
be fairly-- rapid and sudden and dramatic.
But innovation is really long and hard.
And I think you see that with the transistor.
Not just how long it took to develop it to
the point where it worked, but also it was
quite expensive in the beginning.
And in those early days, it was really kept
alive by defense contractors.
Bell Labs put them into the Bell system.
But defense contractors and the U.S. government
were ordering them because the low power requirements
of transistors and their tiny size made them
quite invaluable in submarines and airplanes.
And the extra expense, because they were much
more expensive than vacuum tubes at the time,
was outweighed by those other attributes.
The silicon solar cell wasn't quite as hard
to develop.
However it was incredibly expensive.
I think a year after they developed this device,
Gerald Chapin, one of the inventors, calculated
if he wanted to outfit his house with enough
solar cells to actually power all his appliances
it would cost one point five million dollars.
We're obviously at that point where that cost
per cell is coming down dramatically.
But obviously, the economics made it completely
a non starter essentially.
And in fact they, realized this after they
did that installation, that demonstration
in Americus, Georgia.
That for the amount of, for the expense for
creating these solar devices at the time,
just wasn’t worth it.
Fourth, I think we see from these two examples,
at least at Bell Labs, that there was no way
of making a set way for making a breakthrough.
The transistor was an orchestrated mid-sized
team.
It was very carefully created.
And it was very closely managed in many respects.
There was a good deal of freedom there, but
everybody kept tabs on progress.
And there were very frequent meetings.
The solar cell--.
As I said, all those guys worked in different
buildings.
They found the right problem at the right
time with the right people at the right moment.
It was fairly serendipitous.
Finally, I think that even when we think we
understand the value of breakthroughs, maybe
we don’t.
I think early on the transistor was obviously
viewed as a replacement for the vacuum tube.
And it was.
But its real value has been in computers,
obviously.
In the chips.
And they power our phones and laptops.
And god knows everything else.
I think when I was looking in the archives
at AT&T there was only one letter, as far
as I could find, from an MIT professor named
Jay Forrester, a couple days after the transistor
was invented.
And he wrote to these guys and he said, “hey
can I get a couple samples?
I think those have some real applications
in this computer apparatus that I'm building.”
And its a little unclear from the responses
at Bell Labs whether they realized how valuable
that would be for computers or not.
What they did do was immediately write back
to Forrester.
And they were not writing back to everybody
because they got tons of letters begging for
samples.
But they wrote back to him immediately and
said “yes, they are on their way.
Please let us know if there is anything we
can do to make it easier for you.”
And a quick other thing as for how we don't
know if we understand the value of what an
innovation might do.
Is that sometimes I am asked, “What was
the great thing that came out of Bell Labs?
Or the greatest?”
A very hard question, actually.
Sometimes, I find it depends what field of
technology you work in.
You can get very different answers, but I
usually say the transistor.
And I think it's widely understood to be the
great invention of the 20th Century.
But I wonder in 20 years if maybe the solar
cell might compete in some ways.
If it's a matter of where you are in time
when you answer that question.
One thing I know for sure is that it wasn’t
the picture phone.
[laughter] But the picture phone is interesting
too.
I'll just end on a quick note here.
The picture phone was just a colossal flop.
This was the model one which was unveiled
at the 1964 World's Fair.
They actually re-did it before it was rolled
out to the public in 1968.
The model two is a little sleeker.
It was a square actual model.
But it was in the days before the web, the
internet.
Everybody else had to have a picture phone
if you wanted to talk to somebody on a picture
phone.
The system wasn't ready.
It was fabulously expensive.
It was hundreds of millions of dollars went
down the tubes on that.
It's a classic example, I think, of how an
innovator can maybe get the sort of right
idea.
But if you're wrong by about 40 years, you're
in trouble.
And one thing that actually came out of the
picture phone research was that the labs always
have these guys who are not just building
these things.
But the research department were sort of testing
them with subjects and psychology and human
factors type work.
And they realized it was actually easier to
lie to somebody while you were talking on
a picture phone.
Than if you're just talking to someone on
a telephone.
And apparently you attend to the content and
truth of the conversation much better if you're
just talking on the phone.
I don’t know if the lesson to that is if
you want to lie to somebody, call them on
Skype or have a chat with them on the web
or not.
[chuckling] That gives you a little bit of
flavor for the labs I think, at that particular
time.
There's many more in the book.
It's a long book.
It gets into all these questions of policy
and monopoly, what innovation is, how it differs
from invention, how our world has changed.
And how companies, like you guys, have taken
up the mantle to some extent of how innovation
happens and how it has become more distributed.
With science maybe more relegated to our national
laboratories and our universities.
But it has a little bit-- hopefully this gives
you a little bit of flavor.
That overriding point I'd just like to make
in closing is that, I think, these two examples
and many others in the book, really show that
a small number of people working within a
large organization can make just unbelievable
changes in the world.
And I don't mean just a social impact in how
we live, but also just a huge economic impact.
When we consider the platform industries that
came out of these two inventions.
And those ripples that are still really spreading
out from them.
And obviously it wasn’t just Bell Labs.
Other people picked up on this and made it
better and better and better.
There's a whole other story of what was going
on in the West Coast-- Fairchild Semiconductor
and Intel and how they made it better.
But still from this one place came what has
been millions of jobs and a real revolution.
Thank you.
[ applause ]
So, I am happy to take in questions if anyone
wants to ask anything.
Yes.
Sure.
Oh.
I can't--.
It's a little bright.
I'm sorry.
Hi.
>>Male #1: I don’t know if you've had a
tour of the building or other Google facilities.
OK.
But there's a real estate and workplace services
group that has taken a lot of effort to design
the physical spaces to encourage interaction
and informal.
I wonder if you could say something about
–. I think this has been in some reviews
of your book about the physical layout of
some of the Bell Labs facilities that encouraged
interaction.
>>Jon Gertner: Sure.
Yeah.
That old slide of Murray Hill I put up.
They created these epically long hallways
so people could interact.
Made it almost imperative that you would bump
into people.
At the same time, they situated.
They didn't sequester departments.
Mervin Kelly was quite intent on mixing development
people in with the research people, abutting
chemistry, physics, and metallurgy.
It in some ways seemed like it didn't have
a rhyme or reason, but it worked very well.
Another example of that is the MIT Rad Lab,
which you may have heard about, too, which
was a little bit of chaos, but was a very
creative environment.
Kelly was a big believer that great ideas
don't come from like-minded people talking
to each other.
They come from that interface of people with
different points of view and different expertise.
>>Male #2: Seems like one hell of a thing
to devote five years of your life to.
What put you on to it?
>> Jon Gertner: Great question.
I actually grew up near Bell Labs in Berkeley
Heights, New Jersey.
So.
My dad did not work there, although he was
a scientist.
But I was--.
I am a journalist.
I was writing about technology and society
and economics to some extent.
And I was particularly interested in innovation.
And I was looking for a book project after
writing a lot of long stories for The New
York Times Magazine, wondering what I could
devote a lot of time to.
And I had been writing about Innovation and
Toyota and some other companies.
It occurred to me that I really did want to
write about Bell Labs.
It was a great place.
I didn't really think it would take five years.
[chuckles] I think the original plan was two
years.
And then I remember just that first year driving
back with interviews from veterans.
Or going to at the time Holmdel, the old labs
was still open.
And there was Murray Hill.
And I would be just excited by the amount
of stuff that there was to write about.
But also sometimes with just a pounding headache,
how difficult the task was gonna be.
And it was difficult.
It was –. I'm sure all books are difficult
in their own way.
I think in this case with Bell Labs, what
story do you want to tell?
And some people have read the book who even
had nice things about it, said, “You don't
write much about UNIX and C.” And that’s
true.
And I think that's, to me, that was a little
different than the story I was telling about
five people who formed the core of my narrative.
I think the computer labs at Bell Labs is
going to be a great book in itself one day.
But that was not this particular one.
So narrowing it down and figuring out a way
I could some how manage the story of this
place, was also a great challenge.
Anyone else?
I'm not an engineer.
So you could totally stump me if you want.
No?
OK.
[laughter]
>>Male #3: Well, first of all, let me just
say I look forward to the computer sciences
book that you are going to write later.
[ laughter ]
Big surprise, a lot of us from Bell Labs ended
up here.
>>Jon Gertner: Yeah
>>Male #3: What else was sort of the legacy
of Bell Labs?
There was the big earthquake in '84, but in
my experience at least, it still took awhile
for things to shake out.
It wasn’t until really until roughly about
the same time as the dot com boom before you
started seeing the major exodus.
Where did people go?
Did they retire?
Did they retire in place?
What happened?
>> Jon Gertner: It's a great question.
I was looking for metaphor in the book for
that.
I called it an inheritance in some ways.
It was this vast sum that got split apart
among descendants . It's true.
There was a good amount of momentum after
the break up.
And Bell Labs was still a very, very good
industrial lab.
For a number of years after.
They are still doing good stuff, too.
Although the mission is much more narrow.
Some people were split off.
The math folks, some went to the Shannon Labs
at AT and T when that was created.
Some went to Bellcore.
Some went to academia.
Some went to the west coast where they realized
they could actually make more money than they
ever thought possible.
[chuckles] Some retired and that's true.
And some did stay there.
Because again, there was this momentum where
some of the older people could stay there.
At the time of the break up it wasn't necessarily--.
It was very unclear.
Reading the press in the mid 80s about what
would happen to the great AT and T and Bell
Labs.
There was no sense that somehow it was doomed
or that there would be such disruptive changes.
And in fact, it was gonna be AT and T and
IBM which were gonna compete in the computer
business.
And that was gonna be the big square off.
Yeah.
>>Male #3: It's funny there was maybe a lot
if inertia.
When I joined in '81, there was this weekly
publication called Bell Labs News.
And at the back there were all the anniversaries.
Every week.
Every week there was at least one person celebrating
his, almost inevitably his, 40th anniversary
at Bell Labs, which is just unimaginable today.
>> Jon Gertner: Yeah.
It's incredible.
It was a gold watch sort of place, I suppose.
That doesn't exist anymore.
Or does exist.
But certainly not in technology.
And I don’t think, certainly the book is
not an act of nostalgia.
I think it's interesting that things have
changed.
As a journalist, it's interesting to watch
things become faster, companies more agile.
To see what happens when engineers and entrepreneurs
can switch companies quickly.
But there was something to say about that
institutional knowledge.
It was really there and you could tap it.
And those guys knew stuff.
In that sense it was very valuable.
And things if they moved slower, they could
take the long view in the the way that obviously
could pay off in very dramatic ways.
>> Male #4: Hi.
>> Jon Gertner: Hey
>> Male #4: Do you think this notion of the
research lab is economically feasible today?
I seem to be reading more about the decline
of these research labs, like with Park and
such, than any kind of successes.
Maybe Microsoft Research.
Beyond that, I can't think of any dedicated
research labs that would have the success
of Bell Labs.
>>Jon Gertner: Would you call Google X a research
lab by the way?
I'm just curious.
>>Male #4: Well it's interesting.
We met actually.
My group is involved with innovation.
We met with some of the people from Google
X.
And who came from Microsoft.
And they say it's an entirely different model.
It's not the academic research model that
was ever practiced at Bell Labs or that’s
done at Microsoft Research.
It's much applied and practical.
And, I think, more short term than the long
term thinking that happened at Bell Labs.
So, I don’t know.
It seems like we have lost a lot since then.
>>Jon Gertner: Yeah.
Believe me.
I have struggled for years on that question
of how does one--.
Eventually I just had to sit with contradiction.
That seemed to me to have no resolution that
monopolies are bad for consumers.
They limit choice.
They can slow the rate of innovation.
They can increase prices dramatically.
And yet, they also created this curious institution
of Bell Labs.
That could take this long view because it
was attached to a parent company.
And therefore could think long term.
And it could terminate research without any
problem at all.
And just move on to the next thing.
And just write it off.
Do I think research lab's dead?
I think it's really hard for a company to
fund it and justify it.
And I think it's especially hard for a company
to--.
It can be like--.
Even if hypothetically a corporation were
to invest largely in a pure research endeavor,
it seems to me it would just be so vulnerable
to a boom bust cycle.
That to take the long view would be very hard.
What happens when you have a bad year for
revenues?
Or when growth slows?
That's a pretty expensive endeavor sometimes.
I think technologies can make research cheaper
now in some ways than they were back then
with computing, but I do think that to capture
the value--.
To invest in a research lab is very hard for
a corporation because it's very hard to capture
the value of doing basic science, and the
risks are quite high, and the risk of failure
is tremendous.
So, I don’t know what the answer is right
now with the distributed model of universities
and national laboratories in the private sector.
Is it in sum as good?
I think it's a great question.
I like to talk about it.
I come down in different ways on that, but
if anybody wants to chime in on that I'm very
interested in what you think.
Yeah.
>>Male #5: So, the computer science research
lab in the 60s and 70s had a real reputation
for being free-wheeling and counter cultural.
So, it's funny to see these guys hanging out
in their jackets and ties.
When did that shift happen?
Was it always free- wheeling for its times
or was there a cultural shift over the years?
>>Jon Gertner: It was pretty free- wheeling
actually.
Especially in the research areas.
I mean, there was a kind of telephone guy
culture in the 40s, but by the 50s especially,
as I understand it, it started in the theoretical
physics labs where they stopped wearing socks,
[chuckles] but there was always such a great
amount of freedom that dress code fell by
the wayside.
I think, too, that placing Bell Labs within
the larger culture of work.
In general, you would wear a shirt and tie
to go to work.
So, in some ways, I think the dress can be
deceptive.
That the actual behavior and freedom and the
environment was laid back and free.
Even when Claude Shannon , the great mathematician
at Bell Labs, was working on information theory
and digital communications in the late 40s
. He said those guys we were all pretty way
out.
We just left you alone.
If you had something and you were on something,
and you had a supervisor who was on board
with you, you couldn't go for a decade but
you could go for a year or two.
And really just make your own plan.
Anyone?
No.
OK.
Well thank you guys.
I appreciate it.
I hope it wasn't too boring.
[chuckles]
[applause]